I am sure.
The, for many of you who are watching us from non English speaking countries,
the name Jacinda Arden is probably unknown to you yet.
And the Anglo-Saxon world, especially among progressive center left circles.
This woman is becoming an inspiration, practically, an idol of the masses.
We're talking about the current prime minister of New Zealand,
a blood tickle figure.
Who's been labeled by pretty much all the progressive media and the Anglo-Saxon
world as the antithesis of Trump,
the kind of leader that anyone would want to have an his or her country,
something like a new symbol of global social democracy.
Jacinda Arden is showing the world what real leadership is, sympathy,
love, and integrity.
The guardian new Zealand's prime minister Jacinda [inaudible] is young
forward-looking and unabashedly liberal color, the anti-Trump Vogue.
So.
Exactly it's just sent to Arden. And why on earth?
Has she garnered so much praise from certain sectors of the international press?
Well.
Besides being the youngest New Zealand leader and the last 150 years,
she came to power at age 37,
just in the Arden was also a committed Mormon until she left the very
conservative church in 2005 to fight for LGBT rights. However,
despite her current agnosticism and criticism of her previous faith,
the truth is that the New Zealand leader of the Mormon church has only good
words to say a bigger in any case.
The most remarkable thing about her beginnings was not to religion,
but that she spent time growing up, surrounded by social problems.
And we repower a small town with a lot of Murray gang activity.
And one that suffered from being socially isolated.
It was there that she decided to become a political figure.
Arvind joined the labor party very early when she was just 17,
before she even began her university studies,
her first contact with real politics was her involvement and labor politician,
Harry Donovan's reelection campaign.
And the fact is that after traveling to the United Kingdom,
working for two and a half years in Tony Blair's cabin office and becoming
president of the international union of socialist youth ardent eventually took
over the leadership of the New Zealand labor party in 2017. Yeah.
In 2017,
exactly the same year that she was elected as the youngest prime minister,
as well as being the youngest member of that parliament. This is all a very,
very good example of what could accurately be described as a meteoric political
career, or maybe just extremely good luck, either way.
It is likely at this point that you've got more questions than answers.
What led new Zealanders to trust Arden?
How did you become prime minister in 2017?
What has driven her reelection in 2020 has just into art and really being such a
successful leader, or is everything not as pretty as it looks well,
we're just about to tell you, but before we get started,
I just want to remind you of our new channel visual Academy,
where we look at all the best people, places and periods in history.
It's got great animations, interesting stories, and I've always over the,
I think you may recognize you should check it out anyway, let's get cracking.
The great and controversial coalition.
Despite her meteoric rise and the history of successes, champagne, wine,
and roses that she seems to have left in her. Wake.
The truth is that just in the Arden did not become prime minister as the
favorite,
the real winner of the 2017 election race was the national party with its kind
of date, bill English, the incumbent New Zealand prime minister,
who was running for reelection after spending less than a year.
And the rule as John key's replacement key resigned precisely to make.
And.
However, despite the fact that the national parks, one 56 of the 120 seats,
and therefore was only five seats short of an absolute majority,
both the Maori party and the United future party,
which had supported the previous government,
lost their seats to the Jacinta Arden's labor party managed to form an attentive
coalition.
And this was not your typical left-wing coalition with ideological allies.
Not at all. In fact,
Jacinda Arden agreed to our coalition with New Zealand first,
our right wing party with populist overtones.
There was a pack that was also made with what is called an exercise and
confidence and supply from the green party that allowed Arden to gain a
majority. And I used to the national park date from power.
So.
To anyone's eyes, that's a real potpourri, a hotspot of political possessions.
And example of what is usually known as a Frankenstein government.
The point is that this coalition was controversial because although the labor
party was guaranteed to return to power,
it did suit with an obvious minority against the trend of what the majority of
new Zealanders had voted for. And not exactly within natural allies by its site.
This is equivalent to something like a pact between Donald Trump and Bernie
Sanders. I mean, can you imagine that, although now that I think about it,
it actually doesn't sound so strange. Either 2020 has been a weird year anyway,
to make the challenge even more complicated.
The economic and employment performance that New Zealand had had during the
proceeding years under the leadership of the national party had been envy.
The.
Conservative government of John Key,
who governed the Island nation between 2008 and 2016,
the country successfully weathered the great economic crisis by suffering only a
slight recession after which the economy quickly returned to a scenario of solid
growth.
New Zealand clocked up several years with rates above 3.5% year on year growth.
Unemployment also remained a decent levels during that period with rates
averaging between five and 7%. However,
one of the biggest problems for the country during these years of prosperity was
the high price of housing and it's continuous upward trend.
And that was precisely one of the great battlefields for us,
But in this favorable backdrop,
it is not surprising that the winner of the 2017 elections was not Arden but
English. And it was also not surprising.
Therefore the Arden would have to resort to such a coalition to take power.
What affected this medley of parties and ideologies have on the prime minister's
policies between 2017 and 2020? Yeah.
And New Zealand elections are held every three years, not every four or five.
Well, basically the result of this Frankenstein type coalition was immobility
In broad terms I've just sent to Arden,
had been characterized by anything during our first two years in office,
it has been by doing little and what little she has done.
She has done discreetly being associated with a party like New Zealand,
first knit, many of Arden's progressive aspirations. And the bud has,
she had to moderate her policies and turn more towards the center in practice.
This resulted in a government that was in separate to say the least not very
active and incapable of delivering on a good part of the labor electoral
promises, which were centered above all on the price of housing,
gender equality, and child poverty, poverty by New Zealand standards. Thighs,
hold on one moment just into Arden has just swept the 2020 elections that were
held in October.
We are talking about nothing less than the first absolute majority since the
country's 1996 political reform.
So the question is how on earth is it possible that Jacinda Arden has crushed it
and has had such a triumphant victory and this election,
especially when at the beginning of the year in January, 2020,
she was not even leading in the polls at that time, the opposition leader,
Judith Collins was ahead.
So what could possibly have happened to make that scenario turnaround so
radically? Well, my friends, the fact is that soon after these pools,
the Corona virus arrived check.
The historic labor party.
Uh, friends of visual politic.
You may have your own opinion about Jacinda Arden,
but the reality is that this young 40 year old politician has managed to conquer
the heart of New Zealand. Her labor party's result in the October,
2020 elections was overwhelming an absolute majority with 64 seats.
I have 120 18 more than in 2017 and 49.1,
5% of the votes, her conservative rival,
Judith Collins only got 35 seats losing a whopping 21 in just three years and
gaining less than 27% of the vote in total, based on those results,
you could be mistaken for thinking the Arden's first term was an enormous
political, economic and social success. However,
our party's victory is almost exclusively limited to a tremendous stupendous
fermentable and enviable performance and managing the SARS coronavirus to
pandemic. Take a look.
The very first minute Jacinta Arden's government made the decision.
The pandemic response would be led by experts and scientists and not by
political or economic criteria as was the case in Spain, the United States,
and many other countries.
The big difference that this decision made can be seen,
especially in the New Zealand figures and a country of almost 5 million
inhabitants.
This Island nation has recorded fewer than 2000 cases and 25 deaths.
Since the beginning of the past. In fact,
the country has gone weeks without a single case and is even declared the
eradication of the Corona virus, transmission.
Weiss, 8th of June, 2020, New Zealand declares itself,
Corona virus free after last case.
Georgia five 7th of October, 20,
20 New Zealand stamps out the virus for a second time.
The New York times.
Arden government's approach to the Corona virus has not only saved hundreds,
possibly thousands of lives, but also thousands and thousands of jobs.
And in general has put the country's economy in a relatively advantageous
possession. While in Europe,
there are countries whose recessions in 2020 are already close to 20% of their
GDP.
New Zealand has a projected economic performance of only minus 2% year on year.
And that's my friends and the time we are living as quite an achievement,
but how on earth did they achieve such a result? Well,
basically the Kiwis locked themselves.
Don't in their country before the vast majority of countries.
In the world.
The border locked down to prevent foreigners from entering the country,
began there on February 3rd, that's right,
February and any new Zealander coming first from China and later from any other
place have to go through a mandatory 14 day quarantine upon arrival in the
country. And addition by the end of March,
New Zealand had a four-phase warning system best stablish restrictions,
closers and confinements based on transmission levels,
not to mention the clear communication policy that the government has carried
out towards the population,
treating them as adults and therefore making them aware of the risks,
the virus poses,
and also the importance of complying with the rules to avoid outbreaks
All is that that wasn't enough to send the Arden has not waived either when it
comes to standing her grunt as happened. For example,
with a resignation of our health minister,
after he skipped a quarantine imposed by resurgence in July of 2020,
a resignation that everything indicates was actually driven by art and herself.
New Zealand, health minister, David Clark,
quits over handling of COVID 19 outbreak during new Zealand's lockdown,
Clark was twice discovered breaching the strict stay-at-home rules once by going
mountain biking. And a second time when he took his family for a beach trip,
23 kilometers from his Dunedin home, the guardian.
All these early actions have made New Zealand the best Western country,
at least in terms of political and social terms, managing the pandemic.
And one of the countries that's done the least damage to its economic fabric,
which puts it in a very advantageous position for the future.
And this has been precisely the political asset that triggered the popularity of
the prime minister and led her to win the elections. So triumphantly.
And then there are those that say facing the coronavirus professionally does not
win votes. Well,
The situation was such that the opposition leader of the national party,
Judith Collins believes that the only feasible flank of attack and the final
stretch of her campaign had to be precisely that to discredit the liberal
party's management over the pandemic.
Judith Collins says Jacinda, Arden lied about COVID border testing, our N Z.
She promised us all,
and we believed it foolish us for believing her that every border facing staff
in those quarantine facilities was being tested regularly.
Then when it turned out that they weren't being tested regularly and COVID-19
had come back into the country,
we were then told that only a third of them were being tested regularly.
Last week we found out in an official information act request came out actually
only 7% of the border facing staff were being tested, not a hundred percent,
not a third, not two thirds seven, Judith Collins, national party candidate.
But of course, as right as Colin's may have been,
which she surely was at the end of the day, what can I say?
Criticizing Arden for small mistakes,
given the way the pandemic has been managed in the rest of Western countries,
because as if that wasn't going to work and obviously no,
it didn't work.
Perhaps the best battle lane for the final stretch of the campaign would have
been another, because believe me,
Arden shortcomings throughout her administration have been numerous.
So do you want to know what your center has not done at the helm of the Kiwi
country? How's our government had any notable successes beyond the pandemic?
Well, let's take a look.
[inaudible].
Great PR, but not much else.
And there's one thing that is characterized Arden's campaign in 2020,
it's been as low profile.
Her rhetoric has been limited practically to selling her successes in the face
of the pandemic and responding to all the attacks with evasions,
but without concrete policies, she called it a positive campaign.
I imagine she means non-confrontational,
but from non confrontation to political nothingness,
there was only one step and many analysts agree. The Arden has taken that stamp.
And this election campaign,
everything that happened before the virus no longer mattered the first two
years, no longer matter.
And the only thing that people are voting on is the past eight months and which
party is going to be the strongest and the safest over the next three years.
And that's the reason why just into our Dern and the labor party are so widely
popular. They're the only answer for that Morgan Godfrey political commentator
specializing in indigenous mayors.
If we look back to 2017, 2018,
the truth is that the argument government has failed miserably on many issues.
We will give you a few examples here, check this out
in 2016,
one of Oregon's star promises was to reverse the rapid rise and housing prices
in the country. And to that end, the main measure was to launch Kimi,
built a program to build 100,000 public housing units in 10 years. Well,
all of those 100,000 homes, only 258 have been built by the end of 2019,
forcing the government to lower its own initial targets.
And only that apart from not building these promised homes,
they have not been able to reverse the rapid rise in housing prices,
which already poses one of the biggest economic challenges for new Zealanders in
particular young people.
As you can see in this graph,
property prices have not stopped rising throughout the country except in
Auckland, but that's not necessarily good news. Either.
The average rent in Oakland has grown from 329 us dollars a week in
September, 2017 to 349 in September in 2019,
an increase of about 6% in two years, almost three times the rate of inflation.
And it's not just about Jose.
The Arden government has also failed to improve the transport infrastructure
deficit problem that New Zealand suffers from. For example,
they have not built the promised late rail to Auckland airport,
and it almost completely halted roof construction focusing only on maintenance
of existing routes, even though their promises went another way,
what they have done, however,
is considerably expand the policy of social subsidies.
This is where they've really gone to town money for families,
with children to earn less than 50% of the national median income,
more money for college student support and the famous free first year of
university for everyone,
even though the country already had an excellent system of university equity
loans that were the envy of many countries and still begins a long list of
assistance policies.
We'll have to wait and see what affects sharing the wealth have on what was
perhaps one of the most prosperous countries in the world. Even with all this,
perhaps the most shocking fact,
the most surprising one and the one that should concern new Zealanders the most
is that Jacinta Arden claims that the world leader she respects the most is none
other than current Spanish prime minister, Pedro Sanchez. Yeah,
really Pedro Sanchez. Okay.
Current world leader that you respect, uh, you, yes,
I can picture centuries from Spain.
For the sake of the Kiwis.
I kind of hope she copies as much from him as she has copied of his disaster is
management of the Corona virus in Spain, which is to say nothing,
but let's not get sidetracked.
What Arden has been reluctant to do is raise taxes and start regulating
everything perhaps because our coalition partners and our first government would
not allow it. So now the question is,
what will she do with an absolute majority next.
[Inaudible].
Kiwi analysts believes that just send a won't turn too far to the left.
Now she doesn't need to rely on the agreement of another party to carry out our
proposals.
The reason because Arden is aware that a good part of her voters in 2020 have
been people from the center and center, right?
Including national party voters who have rewarded her for her management of the
pandemic. But at the same time, they're looking for moderation.
If Arden starts pushing the button on proposals that are too socialist,
it could cost her her job in three years.
And if there was a consensus on anything,
it's the argument seeks to stay at least for a couple more terms as head of the
country. In any case, just in the Ardennes reelection was a record,
the biggest labor victory,
and at least 50 years after a previous term that every eliminated the management
of the Corona virus would have gone mostly unnoticed.
The question of how long Arbonne will continue to lead to New Zealand is a
mystery.
But what seems clear is that an icon of Anglo-Saxon social democracy has been
born an icon that could even become a benchmark for the global left.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video, please head to the Lake, if you did.
And don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos.
Don't forget to check out our friends, to the reconsider media podcast.
They provided all the vocals on this episode that we're not mine, dulcet tones.
Also,
this channel is possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see you next time.
If you want to learn more about politics and world affairs,
and here's some more of my lovely voice,
come check out the reconsidered podcast where we don't do the thinking for you
find reconsider@wwwdotreconsideredmedia.com or on
Apple or Google play or your favorite pocket.